decía los resultados de las elecciones
penden de un hilo el ganador de la noche
electoral fue jimmie akesson el líder
del partido de extrema derecha
demócratas de suecia tras el conteo
parcial parece que serán la segunda
fuerza del parlamento al cosechar más
del 20 por ciento de los apoyos un
enorme crecimiento respecto al 57 por
ciento que obtuvieron hace 12 años
cuando entraron por primera vez al
legislativo
hoy somos un gran realmente un gran
partido estoy muy orgulloso estoy muy
orgulloso de lo que hemos hecho juntos
para conseguir esto
[Música]
los demócratas de suecia de raíces
neonazis se han normalizado en el
panorama político por primera vez los
moderados el partido de derecha
tradicional ha aceptado cooperar con los
que una vez fueron considerados los
parias de la política sueca
cada vez parece más probable que el
bloque de derechas expulsará a los
socialdemócratas de la primera ministra
magdalena anderson quien no admitió la
derrota en la noche electoral
argumentando que los resultados son
provisionales
[Aplausos]
ahora la democracia sueca debe seguir su
curso hay que contar todos los votos y
esperar al resultado
mientras tanto creo que hemos hecho una
buena elección un buen resultado y una
campaña fantástica gracias
el éxito de la extrema derecha se puede
explicar por los temas que han marcado
la campaña el crimen organizado la
inmigración y la integración una agenda
en la que se han centrado también los
partidos de izquierda los
socialdemócratas han hecho campaña para
reforzar la fuerza pública las
autoridades electorales declararon que
los resultados podrían hacerse esperar
hasta el miércoles mientras se cuentan
los votos por correo